we live in an age increasingly prepared
to see hurtful aspects lurking within
many apparently so-called minor
situations and we're ready than ever to
lend greater public acknowledgement to
it previously being merely private pains
it's in this context that we should give
due recognition to a truly grave hurt
that can unfold within established
relationships when there is almost no
touch left between the parties when one
partner repeatedly moves to hold the
other's hand or perhaps caress their
shoulder or waist and receives no
response at all or a subtle turn away
and with rule we're not talking here of
the more obvious and well-known problem
of a lack of sex though this can be
present - we're talking of the long-term
and arguably equally serious or even
greater hurt that can ensue when one
partners body as a whole becomes somehow
unreceptive - or uninterested in the
other's touch we know of course how much
this kind of thing is awkward on an
early date we're ready at a cultural
level to give due weight to a minor
physical rejection when it happens
around a potential new partner but there
is as much loneliness and agony within
settled couples around under held hands
except that here it feels a great deal
more embarrassing and more humiliating
even to raise the issue perplexingly the
very person who quietly withdraws their
hand or leaves it agonizingly limp in
our own can also be the one who's named
in our will with whom we share a
mortgage and to whom we have given over
our emotional lives how devastating to
self-confidence an inert hand can be in
this situation lifeless in ours this
hand plays into every anxiety about
unacceptability exploitation and
rejection but precisely because it's so
devastating it becomes impossibly hard
to discuss in any fruitful way we are
liable either to say nothing at all or
else to express our hurt through
bitterness and sarcasm
we cannot stay long enough with the pain
we feel to share it and try to correct
it with the partner themselves we may
find it wholly beyond us to develop the
authority self belief and legitimacy to
say you didn't take my hand after dinner
you never touch me of your own accord
and it's driving me slowly but
definitively insane we don't have this
kind of offense mapped out on our chart
of acceptable verbalize herbal
unhappiness it doesn't feel like a toll
we have a language for or the right to
and yet we should despite our anxieties
retain the courage and conviction of our
feelings an inert hand or a lack of
touch is truly a serious a problem as we
feel it is the request to be held and
physically acknowledged is a subject of
deep gravity rooted in our capacity to
tolerate and like ourselves we should
not compound our misery by a sense that
we're not allowed to feel or share it
then when we can manage it we should
learn to pick up the partners hand with
a newfound confidence and say that the
little flinch or inertness refeel when
we do so is a huge problem for us that
what they may blithely dismiss as this
touching business is part of why we're
in a relationship in the first place
that it matters as much as anything else
does to us and if they care at all for
us or in any way about the continuance
of the Union then they will have to take
the pain on board at last we should have
the bravery finally to know in our
hearts that this small thing is not
small at all it's quite simply integral
to how we know we're loved and how and
when we feel we're not
love is a skill that we can learn our
relationships book calmly guides us with
calm and charm through the key issues of
relationships to ensure that success in
love need not be a matter of good luck
for more click the link now